the Joe Rogan experience man are you
hopeful name is gonna work out okay when
you mean this okay this is what we're
all talking about yeah that's gonna
become better a better situation in the
future or is it gonna get more and more
crazy is the United States gonna become
like Mexico I think I got a global scale
we're gonna need each other before
before you know before too long you know
you guys are gonna need Mexico and
Mexico's gonna need you there's gonna be
some sort of situation we're gonna have
to come together
probably you mean like a global war I
don't know could be oh jesus said I mean
there's a lot but I mean yeah there's a
lot of Chinese influences and in
industry in Mexico yes as soon as Trump
said we're gonna when he when Trump was
going in to put into office he said
we're gonna bring jobs back and on this
whole thing so a lot of factories
American factories and businesses moved
out of Mexico and the Chinese moved in
you know well that's what's dumb about
shortsightedness right yeah well not
understanding for deep three-dimensional
chess you know there's a lot of moving
pieces yeah and and and you know people
can say whatever they want about the
United States American companies and
Mexico are pretty good companies and
they're pretty good with their workers
and their ethics are pretty good a lot
better than China a lot better than
China you know it's a it's a different
it's a different game and you know it's
it's again you see these influences
going into Mexico because they realize
that Mexico is a valuable place where
them to have influence in especially
with what you're talking about with
lithium I mean what I mean with battery
technology and green technology becoming
in the forefront of American culture
right now I mean everybody wants
electric cars all these manufacturers
Ford Mercedes they're all coming out
with electric cars Porsche is gonna
electric car now yeah I mean that's a
big deal yeah and those batteries yeah
that's the next you know that's the next
oil quick that oil type situation is
going to be lithium and that's right
next door all right so I think again I
think as a second largest consumer of
American products in the world is Mexico
second largest so
economies are intertwined they have a
lot of Americans living down there
there's a lot of blood ties to within
the country of course Americans don't
want America to be Mexico and of course
a lot of Mexicans want next got to be
more like America that's what would fix
things increasing the opportunities and
making Mexico a better place yeah we
need to make some make Mexico great
again shirts and yeah and get getting
fights at the airport really if we're
connected to Mexico if Mexico was like
Canada where you know like Canada is
[ __ ] wonderful you go over there
there's amazing cities it's it's great
it's safe it's clean if we can make
Mexico like that then we'd have you know
it would be better for everybody
including Mexico including the United
States everybody post-911 at the border
you could see how businesses started
failing in San Diego because it became
harder to cross the border mmm so you
interested since there's there's
symbiotic relation yeah with some of
these border towns specifically
California is very dependent on some
port towns in Mexico yeah we were sent
three a day without Mexicans yeah shut
this whole [ __ ] place down man
there's nothing going on without
Mexicans here yeah
that's why anti-mexican racism some of
the dumbest racism in all of the United
States but particularly for California
it's so stupid I you know I got to see
how like in places like Fallbrook
California where the the avocado capital
of the world cutting down all the
avocado trees because there's a drought
and there's nobody to pick them really
yeah there's less no one to pick less
people coming up and it's harder to
maintain like don't people they hire
illegals and there's holy [ __ ] these
farms need to organize start working on
border control like the whole I don't
know man I I'm I'm one of those people
that believes in borders but I also
believe if you're a hard-working person
who wants to do better you should have
an opportunity and and I don't think a
lot of people particularly
for people that aren't very
well-educated there's not an opportunity
they can't there's no reason for them to
be over here so if they apply for United
States Citizenship
well there's why you want to come here
why I want to come here for opportunity
what do you have to offer I'm you know
I'm a hard worker
there's a lot of hard workers I mean
that's really the attitude yeah you know
and I think we all just got I mean me I
got lucky I got lucky my grandparents
came here dad got lucky that's all it is
it's just luck and to deny that and to
deny these other people this opportunity
this just got to be a way to filter out
bad people yeah
maybe as technology gets better we could
recognize bad people better yeah I mean
I went through a bunch of questioning
they'll clear my background I got a lot
of questions before I usually right I
got a looks and it's fine you know and I
you know I was like you know I didn't do
anything wrong so I'm like I'm here it's
fine
but you know there's a lot of people
like again the Luna Garcia Luna was here
on a green card and he got nabbed when
he went to process his full citizenship
so he was here for a long time
Wow he should just stuck with the green
card I would have kept quiet for a layer
that's why he's in jail right he lied to
a to an immigration agent and that's one
of the charges he has on Wow right so
it's pretty interesting that people like
him have spent a long time of year
things like open secrets and you know
yeah I mean again not all not all
Mexicans good good guys you know not all
humans are good yeah I know yeah so you
know hard-working people come up here I
got some of the people that that i've
met out here that are kind of on the
same boat as I am fresh in the country
you know doing manual labor construction
working at Kentucky ice I met a bunch of
guys that were working on the Kentucky
Derby or the horse stalls around them
all Mexicans you can smell you know the
tortillas the good food is usually you
can smell you know you can you know
where they are
[Applause]